okay so we're trying to make the car run
for half the price that will also make
it run which is $20,000 you're trying to
make your recorder the price which is
five thousand dollars with the solar
panels in something so every ten that
will put the car in the Sun the solar
panels will get the energy from the Sun
and then they'll make it run and the
whole point of this thing is that us
each of those solar panels cost fifteen
hundred dollars so that's three thousand
dollars with panels up there those
mirrors though are about twenty dollars
apiece and each one if it's properly
concentrated on a solar panel can double
the efficiency of that panel so by
putting four mirrors in place for solar
panels that's what six thousand dollars
right there that you don't have to put
into solar panels and theoretically if
you've got a good solar panel you can
get about a ten-time the efficiency
increase if you can control the Phoenix
so in theory if we had a good panel and
10 mirrors we would replace 10 counts
that I've done $1,500 a shot so actually
it should be a very practical thing once
we work out the tracking and all the
technical things that that are going to
make it finally a saleable item this
gathers electricity through the day
stores it in batteries then when you put
it in the garage at night you plug it
into the batteries and it's ready to go
in the morning so the point is to never
have to put it on the grid you can
always run it on solar you just have
solar in two different places extreme
science is the larger project we have a
National Science Foundation grant and
our program is called extreme science
and this is one project of about
probably eight or nine projects that
that the students are doing